how man are you that full-on star and I
said yeah yeah because our [ __ ] Uwe
Gandalf the wizard yeah [ __ ] PID
bastard and then they all passed me that
Bible wicked no one uses wicked anymore
do they
the ability to barbecue I think you
gotta be geezer enough to be in touch
with you with your gentle sides don't
you darling
aye aye yes you have to be able to I
know sure I quite like the idea that
you're a Kashmir caveman Kashmir caveman
there you go it's fun factor has he ever
been on a ladder Oh Prince Phillip does
he like that does he like you yet oh I
think he does I think he does he's
Prince Alexei he's a cheeky young man
he's a cheeky monkey he was very um it
was very sprightly I think he's he was
94 when he turned up and he turned up on
his Tod on a quad bike and he saw I ran
around the gaff couldn't have been more
polite cracked cut my jokes
open to cutlet in ease not Carling
manner or what what I said what the
options are here that's good strides
others should they have wise job here
cider beginning of that sentence
crippled on that one my household went
no there have not been any funny run-ins
with hooligans pushing I did I did come
across some rapscallions up in Newcastle
a while ago and they went they came up
to me at about 3 o'clock in the morning
I've been playing poker and I was
walking home and they will come as
really good how man are you that full-on
star and I said yeah yeah because our
[ __ ] Uwe
Gandalf the wizard yeah [ __ ] bearded
bus
then and then the old whoop ass beat
deck at the one-by-one so I wasn't
really they were football hooligan Utley
there were some rough sorts I have to
tell you he is what you think is a name
is lovely just lovely kind humble normal
proper geezer very disciplined what's
the thing you wouldn't get I wasn't like
we wouldn't expect no I think you would
I think I think you've pretty much
dialed into who he is and that's pretty
much who he is there are no unpleasant
surprises there ah that's my wife she's
pretty handy isn't she well there was
also a character that I played called
Jack Stella if you'd ever seen any of my
work then you would know that he was
referring to Jax teller of sons of
anarchy should if you'd see him that how
marvelous I was would have made it a
little easier for me to get the role
do you have you seen it everybody's seen
it you're the only one who hasn't seen
it who would win but win I didn't answer
your question you're a bit [ __ ]
previous yeah depends you see is you
know Jax is a gunrunner [ __ ] Arthur
plays around with swords so it's more
likely yeah all right fine just answer
the question actually got that Jax would
win I think what was gonna be is a TV
series which I'm quite excited about
thankfully but did present the script to
Charlie today we gonna sniff around
I even out of butchers did it yeah but
I'm very excited too I'm good you know
take that away from me honestly I don't
even need to read the script you're
doing it a minute is he scary he can be
scary yeah hmm
who would win in a fight between me and
Vinnie Jones well who do you think okay
yeah you think me okay all right well
done sir establish that then but that
said I have to also tell you the village
owns
could be the most generous man I've ever
met
life and I really what I really mean
that I see he could be a kindest man I
gave some gold ones you gave you a
shuttle model it's just you know this
isn't about you right now right next to
me saying that he's the most generous
man you've ever my feels quite generous
if you're not as generous as Vinnie
Vinnie's very generous yeah used to
being now was fun yes you as you work
how can you be used to be from oh you're
from Newcastle I would I think this is
our like here well you know it's it's
tricky because I don't sound like yes
you do why does he not sound like a
Geordie to you he's been punched up a
bit since he's been Westside but you
know you can tell us there's an origin
accent there as much as you residency
want to be very proud of it
Sugoi ok I can see it in the future
yes yeah I'd like competition mmm we'd
have a good time on so they'd all sorts
of pull up competitions and push off
competitions yeah after this it goes
back to what we're saying before you
have to keep it fun these films are
tough to make we shoot for six months 12
14 hours a day sometimes five days a
week and it can be it can be a lot of
pressure there's a lot of money at stake
and you know so to work with people that
you genuinely like and make the
experience of it fun it's just the
sensible thing to do so we would have a
laugh and it's always a bit of healthy
competition going on here we go
you see how their aunts who got drawn
out he could have stopped that 30
seconds ago yeah you wait but I didn't
did it well because that anyway you know
for more edifying forage but was it I'll
go off the point this 30 seconds they
get well about 45 seconds ago yeah
anyway I asked another question but it's
tile ask it to make it was me it was him